[Music]
hi and welcome to another season of VM
end to end this is a show where we have
a former reformed VM skeptic pair up
with a VM Enthusiast say we go in deep
into what's happening in the VM world uh
Brian it's good to see you happy you're
here again
likewise yes today's episode is going to
be fun because uh we have a world record
holder on board today this time we're
talking with Emma a while the first
person to ever know what the 100
trillionth digit 100 trillionth digit of
pi was it was Zero hi Emma hi thank you
for having me today I'm very excited to
talk about pie and washing machines can
you give us a quick overview of the of
the world record sure so this year in
2022 we calculated 100 trillion digits
of pi using Google cloud and this is the
second time we calculate pi using cloud
and the first time was in 2019 with
um 31.4 trillion digits and this time we
attribute the digits
um in three years and we use the same
program called ycruncher you can
download it from the web and try it on
your laptop or desktop but the the
change is the performance improvements
in the compute engine platform so three
times in three years but that's not like
um a linear difficulty is it it's
seen more difficult uh the amount of
data you need to move actually increases
faster than the number of digits so if
you want to calculate twice as much you
need to calculate more than twice as
much got it okay so
um Emma has also um talked about this in
a lot of places so you know if you are
interested in like uh more overview or
more kind of historical context please
check out the links below we will have
some additional things but in this
Gathering we're talking about virtual
machines we're talking about compute
engine
um we're talking about like how things
actually you know work in in the cloud
um and that's why I'm excited but I I
think one of the questions that people
often ask or maybe snarkily comment
about when this topic comes up is like
I'm not calculating Pi you know why does
this matter so
am I'm curious like what did you learn
from this and what what parts of that
would be helpful to other people who are
not calculating Pi of course so voucher
machines are everywhere we use the same
virtual machines you can use on Google
Cloud compute engine
um and even if you use kubernetes or
some other management software you still
use Virtual Machine as one of the
fundamental components and all the
optimization optimization techniques are
the same for other applications we have
web servers database servers and
anything else so
it's it's essentially the process of
optimization tuning understanding the
architecture
um and all the techniques I use in these
projects are something I learned over
the years
um as a software engineer and managing
web servers and optimizing web
applications so yes the end result is
five because it's a cool mathematical
number but the journey is pretty much
the same for any other web applications
or or maybe desktop applications as well
got it so you you did a whole bunch of
iterations on on TuneIn trying to figure
this out is that is that fair yeah
um we use um scripts to automate the
process we tried hundreds of different
configurations including OS why crunch
itself the platform we use terraform and
share scripts Ruby scripts to um
um try try everything
um we published all the scripts on
GitHub so you can check it out and
actually see the script and see what
what's what happened
awesome that was that was going to be my
follow-up can can people check him out
see that's perfect
um I'm excited I hope people check that
out yeah I'm I'm actually curious
because this is VM end to end it means
we can go more specifically into compute
and VMS and what it does so could you
nerd out a little bit for us and maybe
tell us or talk to us about Architects
doing this pie calculator on GCE like
I'm sure you ran into bottlenecks and
places where you got stuck where were
they what were they
help us out yeah of course
um so for 100 trillion digits of pi we
need about 500 600 terabytes of storage
and oh memory if you had memory but you
don't have 600 terahertz memory on a
single computer so you need to attach
disks and the maximum amount of for
system disk you can attach your virtual
machine is what 257 terabytes which is
not exactly small but it is not enough
for this kind of calculations so why
crunchy is a single node application we
use a virtual machine with M2 hi memory
128 which has 128 vcps and 864 gigabytes
of memory and we use 32 additional
virtual machines as straight servers and
attach all the disks using network
and the biggest bottleneck is
um storage performance so you need to
move a lot of data
um for 100 units it's 82 petabytes and a
petabyte is a thousand terabyte so it's
a lot of data
um so there are a lot of tunables in the
network platform obviously you have a
different TCP IP tuning parameters
um conjugation control algorithms disk
scheduling algorithms in Linux and you
have like specific very very detailed
way of like tuning the platform and
software to get a full performance and
the last time the network throughput was
16 gigabits per second and this time
it's 100 gigs per second it's six times
as fast and filling the bandwidth for
example is a significant Challenge and
there are a lot of back and forth and
try and errors in the process wow it's
mind-blowing just how much data you're
moving around uh even the storage is a
lot but there's so much more data in
transit it just boggles the mind so it's
it it's really interesting you you have
a lot of data and you need to
get every bit correct you can't even
mess up a single bit then your entire
result will be broken so you need to
make you need to make sure that your
architecture is reliable not only fast
but it's also reliable as well okay so
you have to move
80 some petabytes of data without ever
making a mistake and even a single bit
that that sounds hard
um and and this is you know the second
time you've done a world record in Cloud
so I'm I'm curious with your experience
you know what what was easy about doing
in Cloud what was hard
that sort of thing yeah sure
so it's easy because you don't need to
for example design a completely
different architecture it's not like
building everything from scratch on a
super computer
um but it's still difficult because we
are very very close to the architecture
limits um we use 100 gives per second
ethernet which is very close to what we
have as industry and after moving 82
petabytes of data it's not a trivial
task and and because we are close to the
architecture performance on limits we
had to work very hard and make sure we
um were able to use all the potential
perform performance potentials of the
platform and after after trying out
hundreds of different parameters
we made the architecture twice as fast
so comparing the fast fourth type and
the last the final architecture the
final architecture is twice as fast so
the calculation would have taken more
than 300 days if we just use the first
first prototype that is a good takeaway
for everybody who's you know hitting
bottlenecks in Cloud you know like some
iteration over a test or a benchmark you
know can really help in the long term
and I guess the other thing in cloud is
you know kind of the time and money
mapping are really close so if you spend
half as much time it costs half as much
money to do something cool wow yeah I so
what you just said I'm a recap I could
be a little bit off but you basically
said the first time you did this in 2019
uh the network was a big bottleneck in
2022 it was more the the limits of what
CPUs in in uh not CPUs but computers
themselves can do not so much the the
data traveling does that mean
like I guess what does that mean for the
future of Pi in the future of Pi world
records are we going to stop seeing new
ones broken or what do you think is
going to happen
yeah that's a good question I think we
we can obviously increase number of
digits as computers get faster
um but we want to see more fundamental
changes uh if you want to calculate uh
more digits like 100 times more and
after all in in the 1940s we started
with 2000 digits with the first computer
and today we have 100 trillion days in
seven years so if we want to for example
calculate 100 million trillion digits we
we need to actually solve a local
problems
um the processor is a fast actually the
memory disks not as fast and obviously
we we want to increase the network
bandwidth as well and there are a lot of
fine Q levels
um you need to work on and we probably
want to see some fundamental changes to
the computer architecture and the
software design even if we are just
calculating one quadrillion digits we
probably want to like count
um come up with new creative ideas to
fully utilize the performance of the
um fast computers in the future
oh thank you Emma this is so much to
think about and
um
I I I really I don't know I want to
mention again that this iterated
iteration of kind of testing and things
is something everyone can can apply to
their challenges I think
um and for anybody watching like if
you're hungry for more information about
Pi about uh these world record
um
you know challenges uh about Emma's work
about the math in general
um she's talked to a lot of different
folks in different contexts about this
so we're gonna have some links uh down
below for more info
um and to the scripts if you want to you
know see how she actually tested this
for real
thank you Emma so much for coming in uh
Brian as always thank you for being a
great host and uh yeah next week if if
you want more we've got a a very special
episode with a very special guest I'm
not going to give anything away uh but
definitely stay tuned for that one more
time thank you Emma
[Music]
foreign